qu'est ce que la télévision à tous ceux
qui se posent encore cette question le
cinéma font aujourd'hui une réponse
c'est un français barthélémy pionniers
de la télévision qui perfectionne à
nicolo scop l'icône au scope élément
essentiel de la télévision est placée à
l'intérieur de la caméra électronique
qui assure la prise de vue il décompose
images 25 fois par seconde
la transforme en modulation puis la
reconstitue à la même vitesse jacqueline
joubert présentatrice à la télévision
vous explique ce fonctionnement la
caméra électronique qui se trouve devant
moi est relié par câble à l'antenne de
la tour eiffel après passage dans les
différents services techniques qui
contrôle les missions la tour eiffel de
son côté et mais les ondes qui porte mon
image jusqu'à votre écran personnel pour
assurer une variété à la prise de vue et
réalisé l'équivalent du montage aussi
les mains deux caméra enregistre
simultanément mon image la première me
film entier et la seconde en gros plan
l'image est tout d'abord transmises aux
équipements sorte de laboratoire de la
qualité qui corrige la valeur de l'image
son intensité lumineuse et supprime les
tâches
elle passe ensuite à la salle de
contrôle où se trouve le mixeur
personnages typiques de la télévision
réalisateur de l'émission qui joue à la
fois le rôle d'un metteur en scène et
d'un monteur en effet il commande par
micron les cameramen et leurs mouvements
de caméra choisi l'image est fait
alterner suivant les nécessités de
l'action les différents plans qui donne
son rythme à l'émission finalement
l'image est renvoyé à l'émetteur de la
tour eiffel qui l'a retransmis
rachid et vous serez maintenant on me
voyant aucun mystère dans tour mon
apparition